part part of it is that you you don't
want to fight without a weapon the only
reason you're ever fighting empty hand
is cu I couldn't get to my weapon okay
so when we told him to do whatever he he
grabed okay and you can see it's not a
normal iido grab it doesn't matter okay
so I always have to deviate now I can't
grab my weapon right now what you've
been studying up till now is Project off
now I grab my weapon and the reason for
that is you don't want to grab same
thing you don't want to grab before
initiative has been determined so right
now he actually has initiative which is
even worse but you don't want to grab
where you're going to cause deployment
issues and you start fighting over the
weapon you see no I don't want to do
that camera come
around I'm going to lose this weapon
okay aside from creating
distance I can learn to trap okay so
here what I'm going to do is learn how
to draw my weapon from close range by
creating a zone of
sanctuary so come get every angle
camera okay I'm going to take this wrist
grab and then push
his left arm into his body as I take the
back now I have this arm his right arm
occupied his left arm occupied and now I
create a Zone Sanctuary that I can
freely draw the weapon without a
retention
issue I'm
very relaxed and supple because I can't
hold him here he can just force his way
out you see and I'm in the same
problem what I have to do instead is is
keep myself in the
follow of stick and follow okay so when
he moves I just move with him I don't
ever hold him still he moves however and
I stay on this
corner okay and I only need to stay on
it go ahead enough time to get the
weapon out that's it
so taking yesterday's drill okay I it
doesn't you can change it every time I
don't care is I have to find his
Center I have to take him in the
Tilt I have to uh project against that
Center you see doing all
that but now I add the rotation
and then the
application so I can't keep my feet
still anymore and do this then take it
off and then come in I have to keep the
relationship the internal
relationship start the fight
[Music]
moving keep it smooth then relax
everything is
grounded okay just keep it slow keep all
the elements okay so what I want you to
do is don't go back to it external
movement you should be ground vectoring
everything because you're adhering to
him okay so when I move to
here we can demonstrate
that I'm still ground vectoring so be
ready okay and I'm doing the
technique you're going to push even
harder okay that's how I'm going around
okay got it okay try it again hey you
guys are going to do that last drill
that we did so so so you understand
you're the UK net so you understand what
we're
doing your
ability to take my young energy do you
see and ground it we're not doing the
technique do you understand you see that
it's not it's not I don't care that you
can move me or hold me it's just holding
me and not displacing you is indicative
that energy is going down got that okay
so as she goes you're do the technique
now okay if you come around you're going
to offer me that
hand okay once you get out of it okay
and you're going to walk
around do the technique you feel your
shoulder go okay that would be wrong
that would be standing like this okay it
should she's like this you see when she
did it on me right she's holding me and
I'm coming around and I'm just
walking just walking normal because we
need the
grounding at the speed of life and that
means I have to be able to move and
ground not root and ground okay so
you're going to offer me your hand this
is smoothly grabs right and I'm doing
the technique just like that okay I
don't I'm not going to go like
this get set and then go okay my
technique is going to be just as smooth
as normal walking I will be there okay
no no that means we're not doing it okay
here we go you're the not
right we kind of pause we okay
again we'll do the same side
please there's that pause there you're
rooting you should keep walking walk
better again
walk that
step yeah yep musing okay we got one out
of four switch rolls like switch rolls
sides we do it
again well got disconnected to the
shoulder look shoulder
okay better but I
didn't okay now you're going to move my
mass you're going to do the technique
I'm just going to be there it won't
matter you
go
good now with feet together
well okay so do it on
me
okay hair right just be ready be right
on her and I just moving all of
you okay all just walk into a
curve okay no without stopping okay your
turn
muscle St feet
together you how do we start this St as
we wait for energy to come off of us
then we move which is not it
we stopped okay got a lot of work to do
so it should
be oh this is all ground okay she's
going to push back on you right you're
here she's going to push back she's
going to try to drive back so I have to
be able to be
rooted without stopping so drive on me
and
rooted same thing push on me I'm rooted
although I'm
moving
okay slow down and do more your
energetic each
step Des send your matter on the
touching midot okay good all
right
gra and you you're looking for he
probably doesn't know that you drew the
weapon because you drew it not only in a
Zona Sanctuary but an obscure Zone he
doesn't know it okay so even more reason
not to try to clunch down on him he
doesn't know it and just like in Nea
you're going to uh fake the least path
of resistance so do you see what I'm
doing to your left shoulder this
shoulder right here so here we are when
I drew and do you feel that go off okay
so where does he want to go and that's
where we let him
go rotate project draw start to yield
letting them go and there it is right
there
okay try just like was he comes around
here and you're turning inside of his
Circle okay it's very similar to that he
goes here
boom and I go to draw I start to fake
release and I'm turning inside his
Circle but I can't keep turning cuz then
I stay here okay so if we go back to
here my
shoulder is going to go
forward his shoulder is going to go
backwards that's the turn his shoulder
goes forward backwards mine goes forward
I'm not here I'm on the line
now we turn
boom he never sees
it
boom now tell me what your neck's doing
to the
knife pushing his neck is pushing
against it okay so that's I'm not here I
let you turn I'm off okay I lost control
the shoulders change
places okay and then I've cleared the
lines okay got it all right try